another video allegedly showing our
Kelly having sex with underage girls is
now in the hands of investigators we
learned about it the day after the
singer was released from jail in Chicago
on Saturday an anonymous person paid
more than 160 1000 dollars that Kelly is
owed for child support tarika Dunkin is
at the Cook County Courthouse in Chicago
with more on this story Jericho good
morning to you good morning to you the
State Attorney's Office here in Chicago
was already in possession of two alleged
sex tapes but with this new tape well
that was handed over to federal
prosecutors and it only underscores the
crisis that Kelly is facing I promise
you we're gonna straighten all this
stuff out that's all I can say right now
I promised his child support issues may
have been resolved but our Kelly's legal
problems only seem to worsen this
weekend he was sexually abusing underage
african-american girls Gary and Sally
Dennis a couple from Pennsylvania
announced Sunday they had given a
recently discovered sex tape to the US
Attorney in Brooklyn I thought it was a
recording of an our Kelly concert their
lawyer Gloria Allred said the couple
have never met are Kelly and didn't know
how the VHS tape ended up in a box in
their basement over the years there have
been friends that gave him sports tapes
because they know he likes sports
he has no idea he's tried to think about
it and no idea these are very old tapes
Kelly who was acquitted on child
pornography charges in 2008 has not been
charged in connection with this new
video it is the third underage sex tape
to surface this year allegedly featuring
Kelly attorney Michael avenatti says he
turned over two other videos to the Cook
County State's Attorney these two video
tapes leave no doubt as to the guilt of
our Kelly he is clearly visible on both
videos in his interview with Gayle King
last week Kelly repeatedly denied ever
having sex with minors I guarantee you
that I'm gonna come out of this okay
like I did before and it's not a
bragging thing it's not an eagle thing
so you don't want to address the new
not surface I'm not addressing enough
all right all right Steve Greenberg
Kelly's defense attorney told us
yesterday quote as far as I know there
are no tapes of mr. Kelly and underage
girls meanwhile the family of Joycelyn
savage one of Kelly's girlfriends is
working with Kelly's team to try and
facilitate a meeting with their daughter
a face-to-face meeting they say that
they believe Kelly has brainwashed their
daughter and say they have not seen her
in two years Jon Jericka thank you Rick
I think it'll be interesting to see if
this meeting takes place because the
family tells me that they're they're
always told we're gonna meet we're gonna
set up a meeting and it never comes to
past this one they said looks more
promising than in the past so we'll see
if that if that works out they're hoping
that it takes place this week we will
see by the way your special and the
whole team that put it together did a
fabulous job on you all right
that's so nice of you to say because I
marvelled at that I call emailed Susan
Zorinsky and said how how in less than
48 hours did they put that together with
all new with several new pieces of video
I said bravo Bravo to the superpowers of
CBS being in television that millions
tuned in congratulations to all jamika
thank you again